even harder question
what are the pros and cons of pi torch
versus tensorflow
i see okay
you can go with no comment so a
disclaimer to this is that the last time
i used tensorflow was probably like four
years ago
and so it was right when it had come out
uh because so i started
on like deep learning in 2014 or so and
the
dominant sort of parent framework for us
then for vision
was cafe which was out of berkeley uh
and we used cafe
it was really nice uh and then
tensorflow came in which was basically
like python first
so cafe was mainly c plus plus and it
had like very loose kind of python
binding so python wasn't really the
first language you would use
you would really use uh either matlab or
c plus plus like uh
get stuff done and do done in like cafe
and then python of course became popular
a little bit later
so tensorflow was basically around that
time so 2015 2016 is when i last used
it uh it's been a while and then what
did
did you use torch or did you otherwise
so then i moved to lower torch
which was the torch in lua and then in
2017 i think basically pretty much do by
torch completely
oh which things you went to lua cool
yeah
huh so you were you're there before it
was cool yeah yeah i mean so lua torch
was really good because
it uh it actually allowed you to do a
lot of different
kinds of things so which cafe was very
rigid in terms of its structure
like you could you would create a neural
network once and that's it whereas
if you wanted like very dynamic graphs
and so on it was very hard to do that
and lower torque was much more friendly
for all of these things
um okay so in terms of pi torque and
tensorflow my personal bias is pytorch
just because i've been using it
longer and i'm more familiar with it and
also that pytorch is much easier to
debug is what i find
because it's imperative in nature
compared to like tensorflow which is not
imperative
but that's telling you a lot that
basically the imperative design is sort
of
a way in which a lot of people are
taught programming and that's what
actually
makes debugging easier for them so like
i learned programming in c
c plus plus and so for me imperative way
of programming is more natural
do you think it's good to have kind of
these two communities this kind of
competition
i think pytorch is kind of more and more
becoming dominant in the research
community but tensorflow is still very
popular
in the more sort of application machine
learning community
so do you think it's good to have that
kind of split in code bases
or um so like the the benefit there is
the competition challenges
the library developers to step up their
game yeah
but the downside is there's these code
bases that
are in different different libraries
right so i think the
downside is that i mean for a lot of
research code that's released in one
framework and if you're using the other
one it's really hard
to like really build on top of it but
thankfully the open source community in
machine learning is amazing
so yeah whenever like something pops up
in tensorflow
uh you wait a few days and someone who's
like super sharp will actually come and
translate that particular code base into
pytorch and it
and basically have figured that all
those nooks and crannies out so
the open source community is amazing and
they really like figure out this
gap so i think in terms of like having
these two frameworks or multiple i think
of course there are different use cases
so there are going to be benefits to
using one or the other framework
and like you said i think competition is
just healthy because uh
both of these frameworks keep or like
all of these frameworks really sort of
keep learning from each other and keep
incorporating different things to just
make them better and better
you